i think that everybody has
been asked at least once to
share their data with a company under the promise
that the data is anonymous so the problem is that
the data that is collected is very rarely truly
anonymous and this is what i'm gonna explain today
first of all the intuition of why this is true
is that data that is supposedly anonymous can
often be re-identified and a very good example of
this was given by an article of the new york times
which was published i think about one year ago
where the journalists could get their hands on
a big data set a big location data set about 12
billion and 12 million americans uh so the way
this uh data set looks like is basically that uh
there are different users so like let's say bob
alice carlos and so on and for each of these users
there is a series of location and data points so
for example for bob we have t1 and l1 so time one
and location one and so on teach you and so on and
the same for alice and carlos and all the users
and of course like we can represent this on a map
as a trajectory so we have the first point for bob
which would be t1 l1 and i don't i don't know like
maybe this could be that you know bob was at
madison square garden like you know yesterday
at 8pm something like that then bob goes to t2
l2 and we have a record for that and so on and
we have of course all of this for all the users
in the data set now actually the data set that
the new york times journalists could get access
to did not have the names in it it was what we
say is pseudonymous we can consider this like kind
of anonymous but however uh the uh the journalists
nevertheless could reidentify some people in
this data set and follow their movements and
actually some of the people who were reidentified
were some collaborators of the u.s president
so now the question is uh how did they do it
how was it possible for them to identify this
data set even though the names were not in it
and the intuition of how you could do this is
to use some background information about the
person that you are trying to identify and use it
to match it against the records and the
trajectories in the data set so this
is precisely the idea behind a study that
was published in 2013 by some researchers
which studied this fact from a more formal point
of view so what the researchers did was to define
a metric unicity which we call epsilon p which is
defined as the fraction of users in the data set
that are unique given p points so at this point
we're using this metric they took a data set a
location data set very similar to the one of the
the new york times so a location data set about uh
one and a half million people uh observed over a
period of i think 15 months or something like that
and they computed the unicity values on this data
set and what they found was that epsilon 4 was 95
this means that 95 of the times only four points
are necessary to uniquely identify an individual
in the data set so in other words if you know
you know like where i live where i work uh where
i had dinner yesterday and uh maybe where i go
to train in the in the weekend then most of the
times these are enough to uniquely identify my
trajectory in the data set and once you can find
my trajectory you can see all the other places
that i've been visiting for the past 15 months
this study uses a pretty simple attack
setting right so basically the adversary
is assumed to have access to four points about the
the target the victim and uses these four points
directly to match them against the data in the
data set so okay this is a this is a a potential
a potential setting and but you could think of um
more complex attack settings for example you could
you could assume that the the background
information that is available to the adversary
uh is actually referred to a period which
is different previous to the one of the
data set that you are trying to reidentify we can
suppose that we have two data sets one from 2018
this data set also contains the names so
you know that this one is bob this one is
alice the third one is carlos and so on so you
have the location trajectories plus the names
then you have another data set from 2020 which has
again you know all the uh trajectories of all the
users and so on but in this case you do not have
the names you just have some pseudonyms so for
example this is user one user two user three and
so on now for simplicity we can also assume that
the two data sets contain the same users so we
can write this but we do not know which users
correspond to which ones right so it might be
for example that bob is u3 and alice is u1 and
carlos is u2 so the attacker doesn't know this but
the the aim of the attacker is precisely to find
out the correct maxim between the users in the
2018 data set and the users in the 2020 data set
in this case we cannot uh use the the method that
we we used before right because if we try to match
the points in in the data set on the left
with the points in the data set of the right
we find no matchings because the time periods that
uh this refers to are exactly there is no overlap
exactly so we need to find something more
more clever and one possible way to approach
to approach this problem is to proceed with two
steps the first step is to find a similarity score
between all the users and the second step is to
use all these this scores that we have computed
in order to find a good global matching between
all the users on the left and all the users on the
right so we have here matching so i will go now
a little bit more in detail for these two steps
i will assume for simplicity that there are only
three users in each data set of course this is a
an oversimplified setting right but it's just to
to make things clearer the first step is to find
similarity scores between users what you do would
be to take alice's record and you once record
and you compute the similarity score between
these two and you maybe you find you know like
that this is a 26 percent then you do the same
between alice and u2 and you find that this is
i don't know 35 then ali send you three and you
find 87 so you know like in this case it looks
quite likely that uh alice and u3 actually are
the same the same person but it's not always so
easy you know like because the problem is that
now you have to do the same also for bob and u1
two and three and carlos and you want u2 and
your three and sometimes it's quite clear
which one is the right match but sometimes it's
not that clear so now the main question for this
step is how do we compute the similarity between
two trajectories so there are a lot of ways
to do this one simple one for example here for
alice we compute the set of preferred locations
so the locations that alice visits the most often
and we do the same for u1 and then we compare them
and the idea is that uh if the two sets
of preferred location kind of overlap then
probably this is a good match and of course
like this might not always work right i mean
maybe alice changed the workplace or maybe
that italian restaurant that she used to love
had to close down because of brexit whatever but
the idea is that on average if the overlapping
is good enough then probably the the matches
is a correct okay so and so this this is the
first step the second step is the matching so
now we have all the scores between the users
but we need to find what is the
correct matching so here the idea is to
select the matching that maximizes the overall
similarity between users what you can do is to try
all possible matchings and compute the similarity
scores for that so for example we can start
from this very simple matching in the same order
we compute the similarity score for this one
and we proceed with the next matching so maybe
we can do this one we do this this and this and
we compute the similarity matrix so this would be
like similarity one similarity score two of course
this is the similarity again for all the uh like
the sum of all the similarities score for for all
the the users and we proceed like this for all the
matchings now the problem is that uh this strategy
works uh in theory but it doesn't work in practice
if the data set is uh too big and actually it
doesn't have to be all that big because you
know for those of you who love combinatorics
you can see that the number of all possible
matchings that you have to try is n factorial
where n is the number of users in the data set if
n is just three users then three factorial is just
six so this is totally doable but if the
number of users is one thousand for example
then one thousand factorial is a huge
number it takes i think 2 500 digits
just to be written down so basically you know
computing the global similarity for 1000 users
in this way would be would take forever it would
take like you know millions and millions of years
so we cannot do that um fortunately at least for
the attacker there is uh there is a there are
well-known algorithms that do precisely this so
they compute a maximum weight maximum matching
in in an efficient way so one such
algorithm is the hungarian algorithm
i will not go into the details of this algorithm
because you know like it's quite complex uh but
you can find some very good uh videos online if
you're if you're interested so basically once you
once you have this similarities course you
use the hungarian algorithm to find the the
maximal matching the the most most likely
matching and you use that matching as a guess for
uh the identification of the the users in the
in the 2020 data set and this attack uh works
pretty pretty well at least when the data
set is not too big so a few thousand users
uh but there are you know like other solutions
that are more robust and like you know work also
for for uh bigger data sets so uh i hope i gave an
idea of why you know anonymous data can often be
re-identified so i talked about location data
but actually these kind of attacks work for
most types of um of a behavioral data so all
social networks and so on credit card data
so now one when you when you see this these
attacks you could think that it's really
impossible to to share data to analyze data
without compromising uh privacy and this is
actually a problem because you know sometimes you
do want to uh give the possibility to analyze data
so for example you know uh you might want to to be
able to share uh health data for medical research
but actually i mean there are there are a lot
of examples of how to how one can use data for
uh for good um so the good news is that uh
some i mean many researchers and cryptographers
are you know developing technologies that allow
precisely to analyze data without compromising the
privacy of the individuals who who contribute with
their data but this is for another video and then
down here for each of the value as i'm writing
it out i go round in a loop around the amount of
stretches i want and i basically add in new data
so if i'm going from this point to this point any
device which is keeping track of time in that way
we'll get really confused and we basically get
[MANUAL PUBLISH]